so bicep curls are the perfect example
of an exercise that gets branded as
being non-functional you have a lot of
people saying why do curls when you
could be doing compound movements the
truth is though that there's nothing
non-functional about curls at all in
fact bicep curls can be really useful
building big biceps is useful whether
you're climbing whether you're getting
someone in a headlock whether you're
carrying something like shopping or a
child there's all sorts of reasons to
train your biceps and isolating them
with curls is a great way to stimulate
growth that said they could be better
and if you want to not only grow your
biceps faster but also develop a more
functional and powerful upper arm then
there are some slight tweaks and
variations that you might want to
consider and as you might have guessed
we're going to go over those here
boom my tops off i thought what we'd do
is we'd go over some of these better
curls some of these alternatives and
variations and as we do we'd use that as
an opportunity to talk a little bit
about bicep anatomy and why this is a
better way to train the arms we're going
to start with circular curls
which is something that i've seen pat
mcnamara do as well as a couple of other
people and basically it's going to look
like this you grab your dumbbells
and then you curl up the arms together
move into a
wide position
and then do the same i've seen people do
this with fat bells and that works
really well
but you can do it
with dumbbells as you can see just
perfectly fine essentially drawing
circles
at the same time as curling
with that said i would add a slight
variation to this by curling upwards
like so
but then stopping at the bottom and
changing direction and now bringing them
up apart and bring them down together
[Music]
so
you're basically doing both directions
whether you want to do five reps in one
direction and five in another or you
just want to alternate i just recommend
you use both directions the reason that
the circular curl is useful is that it
trains the inner and outer head of the
bicep so your bicep is actually made of
two muscle heads they have separate
insertion and origin points and then a
shared muscle belly although there are
no fibers shared between the two and
these work differently depending on the
position of your arms and when you
maintain a more external shoulder
rotation then you'll be training the
inner bicep head more likewise when you
have an internal rotation you're working
the outer head more so by using a
circular motion you're able to target
both heads at the same time thereby
developing a more well-rounded looking
bicep resulting in a better peak and
greater overall strength that's why i
also recommend that you switch
directions because if you only go in one
direction then you're performing the
eccentric
with one position and the concentric
with another position and you're not
doing both however if you switch
direction
then this is going to fix that problem
you'll be doing both eccentrically and
concentrically this also maintains a
nice constant motion which can help to
pull blood in the area and really build
a nice amount of pump next up are cross
body hammer curls so did you know that
the biceps are not actually the
strongest muscles in the upper arm
rather that distinction goes to the
brachialis which is situated much deeper
and actually if you tense your arm here
at the side
and you have enough definition it looks
like a small bulge on the side of the
arm here so it's located a bit deeper
but it actually plays a bigger role in
flexion of the elbow in fact it's 50
stronger in this range of motion what it
doesn't do however unlike the biceps is
play any role in supination or pronation
of the wrist so if you're maintaining a
neutral grip just like this so this is
supinated this is pronated and this is a
neutral grip and if you maintain this
neutral grip then you're removing that
pronation and supination so you can just
focus
on training through that single range of
motion just the elbow flexion thereby
you're not going to tire out the biceps
as quickly and you can work the
brachialis much harder not only does the
brachialis make your arm look cooler and
more well defined from the side
but if you maintain a bicep peak then
actually pushes the bicep heads up a
little bit further giving you a nicer
height there so
aesthetically there's lots of reasons to
train the brachialis and in terms of
performance while it's the strongest
muscle in your arm you do the math it's
great for rope climbing and all kinds of
other movements where you're maintaining
a more neutral grip with that being said
any exercise you do for your biceps such
as a curl will also train your
brachialis simply because it's the one
that's working the hardest this is just
a great way to get a little bit extra
performance out of it when your biceps
might otherwise start lagging
maintaining a neutral grip is also
really nice for the wrist if you have
any wrist issues or elbow issues then
this can mitigate those allowing you to
perform more reps nonetheless which is
why i like to use it as part of a
mechanical drop set do as many
regular curls as you can switch to
cross-body hammer curls
and then
go until failure and you can even then
switch to cheat hammer curls
like this
at the end
there you're using just a little bit of
momentum to help yourself through the
movement at the point where you no
longer have the strength in the tank to
continue performing curls regularly
so act as a kind of assisted rep
and if you're getting the momentum from
your legs rather than your spine then
you're not putting yourself at risk of
injury by doing that
next up is one of my favorite moves i've
been doing forever and this comes from
sylvester stallone's book sly moves it's
called the dumbbell runner and
essentially going to be holding
dumbbells and then slow motion running
on the spot like baywatch and this has
been for all sorts of reasons which i'll
explain now going to maintain a
staggered stance position you're going
to hold a dumbbell in each arm lighter
than you'd normally use
and on the one side you're going to do a
hammer curl
at the same time as bringing your arm up
slightly with the shoulder
and on the other side at the same time
you're going to be forming
a tricep kickback don't worry if you
can't go completely horizontal to the
ground that doesn't really matter
and it's gonna look like this so you
switch over
both the hammer curl and the dumbbell
runner will also work the
brachioradialis which is this forearm
muscle here
which also plays a role in elbow flexion
but only when the hand is semi-pronated
such as in a neutral grip this can
strengthen the forearm and again adds
more cool detail at the same time what's
really cool about the dumbbell runner is
that you're training not only your
biceps but also your triceps and your
shoulders so in terms of aesthetics and
definition if you want a more full and
impressive looking bicep then you also
need to train the shoulder and the
tricep
first of all the tricep is actually
supposed to be two-thirds of your upper
arm compared to the one-third that is
made up by the biceps so if you want
bigger arms then just doing loads and
loads of curls is actually misguided you
want to be doing lots of tricep stuff as
well of course this is a video about
curls i'll talk about triceps in future
maybe but
this is a great way to be training both
at the same time at the same time if you
want a better looking bicep then you
also need that additional definition
that comes from having larger shoulders
and the great thing about this is from a
functional standpoint that the biceps
actually are biarticular that means that
they span more than one joint they span
the elbow joint and the shoulder joint
and they assist not only with stability
of the shoulder during something like a
curl but also with shoulder flexion
helping you to raise it such as when
you're performing an uppercut or any
other movement like that
the problem with performing only regular
dumbbell curls is that you're only
performing curls with your wrist in one
position and your shoulders in one
position and this can lead to imbalances
and a great example of this is how
performing only supinated curls means
that you aren't training your wrist
extensors to the same extent that you're
training your wrist flexors which can
lead to problems like tennis elbow
lateral epicondylitis so
essentially when you perform a curl
you're also performing a
isometric hold an isometric contraction
as you prevent your wrist from bending
that way this involves the wrist flexors
which are responsible for flexing the
wrist of course and these are again by
articular they travel across the wrist
and the elbow joint so if you're
performing only this movement what you
can end up doing is strengthening the
wrist flexors more so than the wrist
extensors and you actually can end up
feeling this in your elbow so a great
way to solve this problem is simply to
flip the hand over into a more pronated
position and then perform like that you
can do this by rotating the wrists at
the top or the bottom of the movement
like a supinating curl or a zotman curl
however i personally think it's best
just to do both do some regular curls
and do some pronated grip curls as well
you can do this with either a barbell or
with dumbbells
so next up are ring pull-ups and the
great thing about rings is that you have
to engage lots of stabilizing muscles in
order to prevent them from wobbling all
over the place whilst you're trying to
pull yourself up at the same time when
you perform ring pull ups you have the
option of twisting the arms on the way
up and moving them in a range of
different positions
and this allows you to practice
switching the grip just as we've been
talking about with the dumbbells at the
same time by performing pull-ups or
chin-ups of any sort you're changing the
strength curve so
pull-ups and chin-ups are great to
combine with curls
pull-ups or chin ups with
rings even better
another great option if you've got rings
is to make them a little bit longer lean
back and perform a supinated bodyweight
row then changes the angle of resistance
it puts a nice deal of pressure on the
bicep when it's fully stretched making
it a nice weighted stretch which is
fantastic for hypertrophy in my recent
video discussing resistance bands i also
talked about how you could achieve a
similar thing using one of those
[Music]
so the next exercise isn't strictly a
curl like at all but it's still a really
cool exercise that will build bigger
biceps and really fortify them against
injury as well as being a great
precursor to a lot of cool calisthenics
moves so i'm talking about the
pseudo-planche push-up the idea here is
to perform a push-up but with your hands
turned backwards a bit further down your
body and at the top of the movement
you're going to completely straighten
out your arms what this does is it
strengthens your straight arm strength
so because your arms are locked out and
you're leaning forwards a lot of
pressure is going to go on to the
anterior deltoids but also the biceps
and the biceps tendon and by doing this
you strengthen those areas it makes them
able to better withstand great amounts
of pressure this is really important for
gymnastic strength training if you want
to perform moves like the iron cross or
planche or anything like that and at the
same time it can also help to prevent
injury during movements like a deadlift
so it's a great exercise for generally
strengthening and improving your
performance and as well if you want to
planche or do any of the planche
variations or progressions then this is
one of the best places to start building
up to that
and if you have rings you can also try a
similar thing a rings turned out or rto
support hold basically you hold yourself
as high as you can with your arms fully
locked out and wrists turned about 45
degrees outwards this is again going to
send that pressure through the bicep and
the biceps tendons strengthening them so
they don't tear during a deadlift and
giving you an even bigger more
impressive looking arm
i hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around that would
help me out immensely i massively
appreciate all of your comments likes
and shares you guys have really helped
me to get to where i am now and it's
humbling honestly
let me know in the comments down below
what your favorite biceps exercises are
what your favorite curl variations are
both for size and for function and if
you're interested in a workout that goes
beyond just looking bigger and also
focuses on function whether that's
increasing functional strength as well
as mobility even reaction speeds and
focus then you'll probably also enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training there's a link to
that and description down below and
there's a discount on right now during
the pandemic you can also find a link
there to my print book functional
training and beyond which serves as an
introduction to functional training and
how it applies to the general population
and athletes either way thank you so
much for watching this one guys and i'll
see you next time
bye for now